hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well so this is a
fundamental idea to recitative virtue
office
this is Aristotle's biggest contribution
in ethics I would say he makes a lot of
contributions this is probably deep base
this is like the game-changer at his
time was thinking about these things in
terms of them being and to extremes you
remember when we looked at Plato Plato
had these virtues and what it lower
their opposites just single opposites
like wisdom foolishness courage what's
the opposite of that cowardice right is
it possible to go wrong in more than one
way yeah that's why Aristotle can't
Heath when he thinks about it he thinks
about in terms of meat or another way of
putting that is a middle yeah the mean
or the middle position is always with
respect to something like an emotional
response or type of action or some sort
of goods or relationships he talks in
terms of emotions in actions but he also
if you look at the virtues that he talks
about he's thinking in terms of
relationships that we have with other
people and goods that we have in our
life and one of the Facebook's so you've
got some sort of subject matter and
going right with it being in the mean
position is going to be version and
opposed to that are going to be two
different license you can think of this
like a Goldilocks story here's all our
number block story right bratty kid goes
in and busts up a bear's place doesn't
get eaten by them she goes in first and
it takes the porridge and one porridge
as one to hot and the other forages oh
because because Goldilocks a picky kid
and what is that she eats it all right
and then she goes and she has you know
she she lays in bed she breaks the chair
and all the stories right well it's like
that for Aristotle except you know he's
saying that it has to do with our
dispositions
what we developed within ourselves or
our character there's a middle position
that's just right and we'll talk about
the just right there's there's more to
it than just being in the middle there's
there's some other qualifiers too but
but let's for the first focus on that so
how many different major leagues can you
go wrong you can have two
and that's what he calls excess right
and you can have too little that's what
he calls deficiency and then just right
so now let's think about some particular
examples this will help us wrap our head
around let's think about temperance
again moderation bodily appetites
let's take food is there a right amount
of food to eat for you in the given
situation that you're in
yeah if there's a person but if you eat
too much that eaters like one where some
communities of you too little you and
disorder but if you're somewhere in the
middle
then we'll yeah and that's a good way to
put it if you and if you do end up over
here and you say I'm getting too fat I
got stopped this it's not so easy it's
just saying okay I'm not eating because
you you've now built up this craving for
for having more food and if you have if
you do you know develop say anorexia
which would be a pretty extreme case of
this of self deprivation is it easy for
somebody in that situation to say okay
imma turn it off now now I'm going to be
healthy no because it's become part of
their their being it's become part where
they are quite often it's reinforced by
by the relationships you're right eating
healthy would be eating the right amount
for you and you're you know half the
size of me so you shouldn't eat as much
as I should
I shouldn't eat as much as I do you know
you can look at me and tell that I eat
too much you know I don't exercise
is there a right amount based on the
amount of activity if I'm a college
professor and some of you are quite
active you know some of you are doing
jobs that are much more physically
demanding this is this is about as toss
it gets reviews walking around right
running the chalk on the board that's
not burning a lot of calories
I should probably eat less than somebody
else who's doing a very physically
demanding job reason determines that
what else could determine that well
what's going on if somebody deprives
them self that's probably not reason
that's probably not you know practical
reason figuring out the best thing for
the person deciding that that's probably
some desire some you know some other
thing you may bring reason into it there
may be a certain kind of rationality to
it usually there's some kind of logic
but it's not fully rational what about
eating too much we often rationalize
eating too much don't we you know my big
biggest problem is snacks at night get
out because there's no dumber time to
eat anything we like to get popcorn at
night because you know popcorn is low
calories but you know if you put butter
on it now it's no longer little calories
and if you let it sit in your stomach
all all night you're not actually
burning any of those calories off so it
doesn't really help you can you
rationalize it can you come up with
excuses that seem quite reasonable at
the time for why you ought to do that oh
sure that's easy to do is that real
rationality at work the way it would be
in the verge
no it's kind of a facsimile of rationale
it's really designer that's driving
badly ordered desires let's say we take
another example instead of doing courage
because because I do that an awful lot
let's take generosity generosity would
be the virtue the middle position and
the generous person gives the right
amount can you give too little to other
people what we call person who doesn't
give to other people stingy yeah stingy
skinflint we have miser you know
different words for it could be money
you know it could also be here's an
example sponging off of people and never
you know picking up the bill never
buying the round of drinks always you
know waiting for somebody else to do
that never you know always going off to
the bathroom when the bill comes to the
table that would be over here too it
could be in terms of time the amount of
time that you're willing to give to
people maybe that you know if you're in
certain relationships you should give a
certain amount of time to people if
you're giving less you're being kind of
stingy with your time you're not being
generous is it possible to give too much
yeah to not have limits now this could
happen in a lot of different ways you
could be the kind of person who gets
taken advantage of by other people is
that going to be good for you I mean
when you're virtuous that's not only
good for other people that's good for
you if you're unable to say no to people
who ask you for money if you have no
limits on how much you're willing to
give you're going to be broke pretty
soon aren't you and then you won't be
able to go then you'll be over here
you'll oscillate back and forth
are there other things I could come are
there some people that you shouldn't
give to whether some people were more
deserving of your your time your
affection your money your resources yeah
oh yeah yeah I mean the fact that you're
virtuous doesn't mean that everybody
will automatically respond to Convergys
around you're right there could be cases
where you're doing the right thing
you're you're doing the virtuous thing
but it goes awry because of that but if
you know that somebody for instance has
a gambling problem
and they're at the casino don't give
them any money right if you can get
ahold of their credit cards take their
craft knives - that would be part of
being a good friend which is
friendliness Aristotle says that
generosity should be carried out not
only with the right amount but towards
the right people and given for the right
reasons shouldn't just be given you know
willy-nilly for any reason whatsoever
because if you're doing that you may be
doing it for bad reasons like trying to
be a big shot or just trying to get
people to like you that's not a
particularly good reason to get give
things away I mean for this you give
because you recognize the real need
there and you're you're doing something
good for
people and for yourself in the process
reason he has to determine that is this
something that you can decide you know
ahead of time so we could come up with
some number maybe some table and chart
okay the homeless person on the street
gets let me flip this page they get okay
to box my my friend who's in this case
here we can help them out anywhere
between 10 and 50 bucks okay at least
two times a month but not more it
doesn't work that doesn't you can't
summarize it like that you have to
actually reason out what the mean
position is and now look we notice that
it's not just a matter of amount
there's towards the right person and for
the right reasons are there any other
important qualifiers that would come in
there aerosol says also in the right way
let's think about being generous again
let's say you're giving the right amount
of money let's say it's you know charity
work giving the right amount of money to
the right people is it possible to do it
a way that is in something wrong that
changes the nature of the
yeah you're getting my stolen money I
didn't think of that that's a good yeah
if you just steal a bunch of money so
that you can give it away that would
that would [ __ ] I had in mind something
like you know you really try to make
them feel bad imagine working in a soup
kitchen we try to shame
we're helping you out here like that
that would aerosol would say you're
totally undermining the generosity yeah
well that's an interesting thing to
Aristotle would what would he say about
cases where you don't have any resources
but does that automatically mean that
you're over here you're automatically
giving too little yeah you could give
time you can give you can get a Socrates
says you can get praise I think you know
some of this could actually be based on
what you would be giving what your
character would be if you actually have
the means some of the other hand up over
here too so the things with the mean you
notice there's a lot of different
qualifiers there's a few other things
that Aristotle says that are
particularly important that comes to
let's say in this case we take courage
as a good example so what are you trying
to manage when it comes to courage
there's the actions involved but it's
primarily emotions what's the main
emotion concern
just shouted you fear right you're also
concerned with these as confidence and
all I think all of you have experienced
that emotions you can have fear and
confidence at the same time like you
remember you know maybe the first time
that you got up the guts to call
somebody on the phone who you had a
crush on and you you're kind of nervous
right so there's the fear and yet at the
same time like there's that is like an
adventure is happening and you know you
feel okay at the same time you're having
mixed feelings
that's fear and confidence or you know
you go into a job and job interviews are
scary aren't they but you can also be
confident at the same time so you can
have these two they're they're kind of
opposites but they don't necessarily you
know cancel each other out when it comes
to fear can you have too much fear for a
given thing yeah I mean if I walk in
here and I say well pop quiz is going to
count for you know three points out of
800 in your grade so you better do good
at that in here and you're like oh my
god the world is ending
you know well that's that's too much
fear right
can you not feel enough here yeah there
are some people who there's some cases
where you really ought to be afraid I
was getting the example in the other
class let's say you're walking down a
dark alley now let's say now you are a
little bit older and you have a five
year old child and it's at night and
you're walking to the car you were out
in the town for something and your car
is in an alley and you're walking down
the alley and it's kind of creepy and
suddenly three big guys start walking
towards you should you feel fear yeah
and if you don't feel fear for yourself
you should feel some fear for the kid
that you've got with you and if you
don't then you're you're you're not
virtuous aerosol so you're actually at
the other extreme which is being
foolhardy there are people who are you
know willing to run all sorts of risks
not because they're actually creators
but because they just don't care they
have little t of anything well that's
not that's not rational that's not good
now here's the one thing I want to point
out about this which of those would be
closer to the me with cowardice be
closer than me or would foolhardy this
be closer to the me which one looks more
like courage yeah fool learning this
right and you know why it looks more
like courage because it actually is
closer to courage so sometimes the mean
can slide a bit that's the case that
will mean that it takes more work to get
from cowardice to courage that it will
from full earnest to courage there's one
other thing that Aristotle advises and
that's knowing your own propensity and
weakness when it comes to foolhardiness
and encouraging all that sort of stuff I
don't know that I'm actually courageous
I may be
or over here I don't have to worry that
much about this at which means that I
need to work on this part over here I
need to steer myself further this way
same thing with anger you know do I have
well at this and that somewhere in here
right now we're all the way here where
it used to be thank God but about here
so that means that I need to steer
myself this way I need to pay attention
to the things over here and figure out
how do you reason how to use good models
to get myself over to this this mean and
I have to really watch the staking what
I'm doing over here is if I may actually
at the virtual because you know what
angers a good example this is it easy to
think that you're you got legitimate
reasons for being as angry as you are
oh you don't this is easy to fool
yourself
sure is when you wind up over here do it
too much you get stuck over you want to
get stuck here that's the goal